yo so I actually heard that you're a
huge Joe Rogan podcast fan
is this true I'm kind of new to Joe
Rogan but you've been you've been you've
been kind of getting hip to his
university I think he's funny I think
he's sarcastic he'd be 11 people just
they'd be saying they sit over and maybe
he act like he's like oh yeah but you
could tell I don't know he might not be
might be for real but I I think it's
funny because I think he'd be joking
with him and they'd be dead ass
seriously oh for sure yeah how did you
how'd you like get it I'm new to the
whole YouTube World figuring out this
that's like the new TV it is dinner TV
and then you like kind of let YouTube
just feed you whatever Rhythm whatever
whatever it is yeah you can you sit
there and wake up if you go to sleep
wake up have you seen um Theo Vaughn's
interview with YG
is the white dude who's like kind of got
the country accent
but he's [__] hilarious he's a
comedian white dude with a country
accent it sounds like he had YG on nyg
was like showed him sexy red
and he was like oh yeah I like me some
of that and YG's like you ever had some
black black ghetto [__]
Obama was like what
yeah that's dope man yeah Rogan is is
great have you learned anything random
from The Joe Rogan podcast because I'll
be learning the most random information
bro
that you let people talk
and they make the money for you you
gotta give them somewhere to come and
talk um
what about your thoughts on are you hip
to what's happening with the alien stuff
right now
because they're saying
you know this guy went and testified to
Congress that pretty much all but
admitting that aliens are a real thing
did you see that
look they're my aliens [__] still
gotta pay their bills tomorrow if
they're before alien raise it happened
you still gonna have to do you think
aliens are real though ESTJ and how much
do it affect Joe but do you think
they're real
I don't give a damn if they realize are
they gonna what they gonna change what
they gonna they gonna get [__] out of
jail I don't know that's exactly so [__]
all that I just know Independence Day
with Will Smith you remember that movie
no
you don't you've never seen Independence
Day when they come out [__] how old are
you you're a lot younger than me yeah
well no you're not that much younger
than me it came out in like 97. I was
three years old yeah it's a classic
though they come and they [__] they
blow the White House up [__] gets real
real raw they were very uh aggressive
they didn't pay taxes at the end of that
cheer problem this is true do you guys
pay a lot of taxes in Kentucky
because I feel like in the South they're
a lot less in your pockets like in
California they'd be in our [__]
Pockets taxes is a
national government Bank no but I'm
talking about state taxes because yeah
obviously you're gonna pay federal taxes
on everything I think it just depends on
where you live at it the property values
high in certain places the minimum wage
is high in Cali yeah so it's like a
trade-off like they pay more taxes but
yeah yeah probably minimum wage like 20
I think it's 20. yeah what is it in in
Kentucky I don't know but it ain't
nowhere
near 20. so if it
so it just add up the same how's uh
what's the weather I've never been to
Kentucky I've driven through Kentucky
but I've never like really hung out
right like summertime in Kentucky is it
humid is it hot like what is the vibe
during the because it's been hot as [__]
I'm from Phoenix
was 119 last week when I was there you
could like cook an egg on the street
what's it like in Louisville summertime
it's hot it's not like everywhere else
we get all four seasons all four seasons
yeah I love it um did you grow up a
Cardinals fan
because there's no obviously
professional team there's the Wildcats
then in Louisville you got the Cardinals
Donovan Mitchell you know shout out none
of them
no no [__] man
we was they ain't giving none of my
[__] no scholarships or nothing had
another one he's getting nowhere were
you at uh at a scholarship at Indiana
State right and not a Louisville yeah
did you try to go to Louisville and they
just did you had to go home anymore keep
talking about Athletic program I got you
I respect that
they hey well it is what it is